The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
guys, let's get started.
So today, we're going
to talk about a very
different and principled
approach to building secure web
applications.
And it's going to be about
a system called Ur/Web.
And right now,
our guest lecturer
is the author of the
system, Adam Chlipala,
who's a professor at
MIT, is going to tell you
more about the system he built.
ADAM CHLIPALA: All right,
so I want to get to a demo
as soon as possible.
But before that, I
just want to spend
some slides setting up part of
the context about this system.
And you've probably gotten
some of that context
already from the
draft paper that
was the reading for this class.
So what is Ur/Web?
It's always good to start
out by explaining what
the name of something means.
So Ur/Web, first it's
a programming language
for building web applications.
That's what the Web
part of the name means.
And it's sort of a
full stack system.
It does everything you need to
do to build web applications.
And Ur is a new general
purpose functional programming
language that is
used to implement
these web specific features.
And the whole point of
Ur/Web is that instead
of having a general purpose
programming language
and then having a library
or a traditional framework
for building web
applications, it's
all integrated into a customized
programming language in Ur/Web.
And it's a language that
involves compilation, not
interpretation at run time.
And the compiler in some
sense understands what a web
application is supposed to do.
And it will point out
mistakes that you're
making that a conventional
compiler, for say Java,
would not be able to
realize where mistakes.
So there are really
three main principles
that I was trying to follow
in designing this language.
The middle one is most
relevant in this context.
But they are programmer
productivity, security,
and performance.
And the last part, especially
on the server side, because that
seemed more important
for scaling reasons.
In many cases, the users
of your application
won't notice small performance
issues on the client side.
But a small issue
on the server side
could force you to buy many
more servers than you would have
otherwise.
And at this point, there
are some users of Ur/Web--
not nearly as much as pretty
much any other language
you probably think of.
But there's at least this one
commercial web application,
which is an RSS feed reader that
supports such exotic features
as displaying comments.
And there's the URL chosen by a
non-native English speaker who
regrets it now.
It's called BazQux Reader, as a
combination of common medicine
tactic variables from
the hacker community.
And there are a few
thousand paying users.
And it looks like that--
much nicer than anything
I know how to make with CSS.
But here's a proof that it
can be done using Ur/Web.
Feel free to jump in with
questions at any point,
though I probably haven't
gotten to the point yet
that provokes many questions.
So the basic sales
pitch for Ur/Web
is that it has a very high
level programming model, which
is very different
from, say, Django,
which I know you spent some
time reading about or talking
about in class.
And it has a good
security story.
Some features you
want for security
are really integrated
into the system
so that you would really have
to work hard to avoid inheriting
these security benefits.
And I'll say more about
the detail shortly.
And also, the server
side performance
is unusually good, even
among the popular tools
for building web
applications that you're more
likely to have heard of before.
And the caveat is
that we probably
need to have internalized
the big ideas
of functional
programming languages
like Haskell before a
programmer's ready to start
using Ur/Web.
And looking at the questions
and answers for this class,
maybe a fifth of
you were complaining
about the functional
programming parts of the paper
being hard to follow.
I apologize.
There are just so
many good ideas
in the world of
functional programming
that it's hard not to
start from that point
and add more cool
stuff on top of that.
And I will try to
avoid any requirement
to know that material
to follow what
I'll be doing in class today.
So the programming model
is really closely connected
to static typing.
And that's not just
static typing like
in, say, Java, which has
a relatively inexpressive
clunky type system,
but static typing
like in Haskell or OCaml.
And these types
are one of the ways
that the compiler
understands what you're doing
and catches mistakes
in your program.
And it turns out that
the core Ur language
that Ur/Web is built on top
of has a very expressive
static type system.
So many of the things
that Ur/Web does
are actually just
exposed as libraries
with no special
compiler support.
For instance, we'll teach the
compiler how to type check
SQL queries without actually
building the typing rules
of SQL into the compiler.
They can be encoded as a library
and use a standard type checker
to make sure your SQL queries
are following the rules of SQL.
Most relevant in this
context, the security story
at a high level-- most of
the most common security
vulnerabilities are impossible
by construction in Ur/Web.
You will have to
explicitly enable scary
looking flag names to be
allowed to do most of the most
awful things you can do
in a web application,
like no cross site scripting
vulnerabilities unless you
really invoke some black
magic, say, by using
the foreign function interface.
And there are a few other
security-specific features
that I'll highlight later.
And the performance
is also very good.
The compiler is, first of all,
a domain specific compiler
for a web application.
So it understands what the web
application is doing and is
able to optimize some things
that a more general compiler
wouldn't catch.
And usually the
code that comes out
of this compiler that
runs on the server
is native code,
which is very, very
competitive with what you might
bother to write by hand in C.
And the performance
costs that there
are compared to
other approaches tend
to have to do with the
concurrency model, which
makes the programmer's
life easier
at some cost in performance.
And I'll say a little bit
more about that in a moment.
Here's a quick plug for this
web framework benchmarking
initiative that is
run by a third party.
This is a screenshot of
the results of the most
recent round where a number of
different web programming tasks
were completed in many
different frameworks,
and they were compared pretty
much exclusively on performance
so far.
And here you can
see Ur/Web sitting
at fourth out of about 60
frameworks on this benchmark.
And there's been
some improvements
to the Ur/Web compiler since
this screenshot was taken.
And I expect in the
next round it'll
move up a little bit higher.
But basically, already this
is a simple example using
SQL to generate HTML pages.
You get about 100,000
requests per second
from the Ur/Web
server, which is going
to be just plenty for
most applications.
So sort of maybe the
important takeaway message
from this slide in this class is
that you can adopt a high level
model that makes security easier
to achieve without just giving
up all the performance that you
would expect to get from more
mainstream techniques.
All right, so let me start
out by giving my cartoon
impression of the way
web programmers think
about writing web applications
in mainstream frameworks today.
And then I'll show the
different perspective
that Ur/Web provides, where
some of the things that
can go wrong at this level
given the abstractions that
are exposed can no longer
go wrong by construction.
So the basic cartoon picture is
there's a web server out there.
And it's sort of in charge
of the whole process
of your application.
And there's a whole fleet
of browsers out there
that are going to
interact with that server.
It'll have some state
that winds up effectively
shared across all these
browsers through their contact
with the server.
So the usual picture
is that the browser
starts interacting
with the web server
by sending it an HTTP
request that includes
some URLs embedded in it.
And then the web
server throws back,
again, the HTTP and HTML page.
And there are some
URLs embedded in that,
which can be used to decide
which request to make the web
server in the future.
This web server
might also be talking
to a database that provides
a persistent store that
is shared across all the
users of the application.
One popular protocol to
speak between the web
server and the database is SQL.
That's what I'll be focusing
on talking about Ur/Web.
And also, with modern
web applications,
it's not just the one
page at a time model
where whenever anything
has to change on the page
you make a new
request to the server
and then replace the
whole page of the unit.
There's this Ajax
style where the browser
within a single page
view will sometimes
make extra HTTP requests
to the web server
and receive responses that
are processed programmatically
in a customized way.
And this often uses
representations
like XML and JSON
and other simple wire
formats for exchanging
data between the client
and the server.
And then when the browser
gets back that response,
there's some
JavaScript code running
there, which implements
arbitrary logic for controlling
the UI that we're
displaying to the user.
And the way this works is
that this JavaScript code
can read the responses
that the server has given
to those different Ajax calls.
And then it can modify the
page that's displayed basically
by mutating a global variable
that stands for the page.
And any part of the
program can have
arbitrary effects on this global
variable that is the page.
And often, parts of
the page are looked up
by string IDs that are annotated
on nodes of the tree that's
describing the document.
And finally, one more
complication-- sometimes
we want to allow what feels
like the web server contacting
the browser without prompting.
So say there's a
new email message.
The web server wants to tell
the browser, new message.
So there are a variety of
ways of doing this involving
acronyms like Comet
and WebSockets
that really look a lot like the
browser contacting the server.
It's the same sort
of thing conceptually
in the other direction.
All right, so I want to
bring back on the screen
all these protocols
and languages,
highlight some parts
in yellow here.
Having read the
paper, does anyone
have a guess about what is
the commonality between all
these highlighted parts here
from a security perspective?
Yes.
STUDENT: They're all strings.
So you can put whatever
you want in them.
ADAM CHLIPALA: Right, in
the mainstream approaches
to web application programming,
all of these things
are strings.
And the programming
language doesn't understand
the way you're
using them and can
help you avoid making mistakes.
So for instance, by representing
these things are strings,
you get code injection attacks.
So as far as I'm concerned,
code injection attacks
are basically about
the consequence
of including as a primitive
in your programming
language or your framework some
function that runs programs
as text in some sufficiently
expressive language.
In Ur/Web, there is no
built-in interpreter
at runtime for
strings as programs.
And that makes a lot of
the most common mistakes
in web applications
impossible by construction.
So all these things
that are highlighted
will either be
invisible, or they'll
be represented with special
types that make clear what kind
of code you're
dealing with and don't
have any sort of
automatic coercion
from string into any
of those special types.
All right, so here's
the alternative model
that Ur/Web exposes,
which gets compiled
to the traditional model.
So it works in all the
widely deployed browsers.
But the programmer can
think at this higher level
and avoid the
potential for mistakes
that were possible in
the previous picture.
So we still have the web
server, which is in charge.
And we still have this
fleet of browsers that are
trying to use the web server.
But now, the first
important change
is that when the browser
wants to initiate use of a web
application, it doesn't just
send a string of HTTP requests
with a URL in it.
Effectively, the abstraction
is the browser names a function
that should be called where the
call runs on the server instead
of the client.
And then the server
responds with not a string
of HTTP protocol text but a
strongly typed documentary.
So instead of a string
of HTML, it's a tree,
a first class object
in the language.
And that is how the
program manipulates
it, not as a string.
And each of these trees
contains within it links,
which are themselves
basically just
references to other
functions that you might
choose to call on the server.
So then the browser, when the
user clicks on those links,
picks out the function
and conceptually calls it
on the server, just like the
original function that we
called to get to this point.
And we have a
database interface,
which is accessed
by the web server
throwing queries
at the database.
And these are not just
text in the Ur/Web model.
They're strongly typed
SQL syntax trees.
And then the database will
respond back with not text,
but a list of records
of native values
in the programming language
that we're working with.
So we don't have to worry
about incorrectly converting
between strings and
native representations,
or native representations
in any other format
that the database
might traditionally
be presenting to us.
And here's a key element of
how the semantics of Ur/Web
makes it easier for programmers
to think about fewer
scenarios that can actually
happen when the application is
running.
There's the standard
idea of transactions
in the world of
relational databases
where you can run a
series of operations
that seem to run
with no interruption
by other concurrent threads.
And Ur/Web adopts that
model and builds it
into the semantics
of the language.
So when a single
function is running
on the server on
behalf of a client,
then all of its
database accesses
appear to happen
as an atomic unit
without any interruption by
any other concurrent requests
to the same server.
And you can't even avoid
this behavior if you want to.
Transactions are built
into the language.
And they really make
concurrency a lot easier
to think about, and
potentially help
you avoid security issues
that only arise when
some rare interleaving happens
with a particular combination
of requests.
And actually, I want to
get to one of the questions
that someone submitted for this
class that I found intriguing.
Ur/Web will detect when a
transaction fails because
of a concurrency
problem, like a deadlock,
and automatically
restart the transaction.
Someone's response
to a question said,
this might make it easier to
launch security attacks that
depend on causing
transactions to fail
because of concurrency issues.
I just wanted to ask
the class, what's
an example of an
attack like that,
if anyone happens
to have one in mind?
If you have a system that
automatically restarts
transactions that
run into deadlocks,
how does that cause a
security problem, if it does?
This is a question I don't
have an answer in mind
for, which is why I'm asking it.
It might also have only
a non-obvious answer
that no one would come up
with on the spot like this,
which is fine, too.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Can you maybe do some
sort of denial of service?
If it's going to restart
a transaction that you're
sending, and you
know it will fail,
can you just keep restarting
that and try again?
ADAM CHLIPALA: OK, so--
STUDENT: So if you
could cause the system
to do some transaction you know
is about to fail and repeatedly
fail, it keeps trying
over and over again,
it would never [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM CHLIPALA: Right, so you'd
need at least two threads
running at once to do that.
But potentially that could work.
So you could launch a denial of
service attack taking advantage
of the fact that
contention leads
to request handlers
restarting over and over again
and purposely cause contention
and use this as a way
to amplify the strength of
your denial of service attack
beyond what you can get
with a traditional model.
All right, I can believe that.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is [INAUDIBLE] the only
way to cause the transaction
to fail?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It is.
Well, it's the only way to cause
it to fail and automatically
restart.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Perhaps it
could have a third party,
which would conditionally fail.
And then you could use that
to monitor some other user's
behavior.
ADAM CHLIPALA: You'd
also need a way
to observe the fact that it had
failed, which you should only
be able to do through timing.
But that could
still be an issue.
OK, right, so you can use
this as a side channel
to see what other
threads are doing,
because their actions
might or might not create
a conflict in your thread.
OK, that sounds possible in
principle, and very twisty.
I'm not sure.
It's hard to think of
a concrete attack that
would work predictably.
But it could be a fun exercise.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So do the transactions
you run-- for each request that
comes in, you run a
transaction for the code
you run at the web server.
But when you send that
code to the database,
does that translate into a
database transaction as well?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It is, yeah.
The whole execution
on the server side
is wrapped in one
database transaction
if the application
uses the database.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So if you have
a transaction that's
not going to end up obtaining,
do you think [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yeah.
STUDENT: Are you
telling the database
that nothing's going
to be updated later?
Because presumably, the
database doesn't know that.
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yes, so the
compiler does static analysis
and finds out transactions
that need to be read-only.
And it creates the
transaction in read-only mode,
which in some database systems
enables extra optimizations.
STUDENT: What about if you
read some stuff, and some
of the stuff you
read doesn't affect
what you're going to write,
but some of the other stuff
you read does?
ADAM CHLIPALA: I see,
so you're asking,
could we use our
knowledge of the semantics
of the application to give
hints to the database system
saying some of what looked
like concurrency violations are
actually benign, and we don't
need to restart at that point?
I think the short answer is no.
The current implementation
doesn't do that.
But that would be
interesting to look into.
I think it would require
changes to the database engine,
not just the interface
in the language.
STUDENT: Usually
you could split it
into two separate
transactions, maybe,
or something under
certain circumstances.
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yeah, that
sounds hard to do right,
but potentially worthwhile for--
I don't know how to estimate
what fraction of applications
could take advantage of that,
but it's a neat idea.
All right, so
transactions are great.
We also have-- so I was just
telling you about the model,
the old school
model of the browser
requesting a single page
from the web server.
We can also have this Ajax
style stuff that basically
looks like code on the client.
It's calling a
function that's just
marked to run on the server.
When it finishes, the result
comes back in the client code.
And the result is
just a native value
in the programming language.
You don't have to worry
about making it into a string
somehow and translating it back.
And then we have
to take the result
and use it to change the
page that the user sees.
Otherwise, it wasn't a very
useful request to make.
So the model in Ur/Web
is very different
from the standard
document object model
that browsers expose directly.
The basic idea is
something called
functional reactive
programming, which I won't try
to explain in too much detail.
Because I know it requires
a nontrivial grokking
of functional programming
first, even if we cut off
that reactive part.
But the basic idea
is the document
is described in terms of a
set of mutable cells, which
are sort of the data
the page depends on.
And the page itself is
something different,
described as a
function that takes
as inputs the values
of those cells,
and then computes a page.
And then the runtime
system of the language
watches changes to
those mutable cells.
And when they do
change, it automatically
computes the consequences
for the displayed page
and efficiently updates
just the parts of the page
that have changed
based on those cells.
All right, and on
each client, there
can be many different
threads running at once.
These threads are
spawned in Ur/Web code
and themselves run Ur/Web code.
But the compiler needs to
translate them into JavaScript
to get the browser to run them.
So that's one of the services
the compiler provides.
That's one important
point about the threads.
Another key point is that
the client side threading
follows what's call the
cooperative multi-threading
model.
A thread doesn't have
to worry about being
preempted by another thread
at an arbitrary point.
There are well
defined operations
that signal, OK, it's all right
to switch to another thread
here.
One of them is making
a remote function call
to the server, for
instance, or asking
to sleep for a certain
number of milliseconds.
But just regular code can't
be interrupted arbitrarily.
So that means the
programmer doesn't
need to think about
as many interleavings,
and it's easier to
convince yourself
that, say, a particular
piece of code
avoids some security
issue or other bug.
Because you can more easily
enumerate all the possible ways
for the two threads to
interact with each other.
And this is sort
of a natural model
to use given the way JavaScript
is usually implemented.
There isn't preemption in
JavaScript and browsers
already.
So this is just presenting
a threading abstraction
on top of the
callbacks-based model
that JavaScript shows
the programmer directly.
And the last piece that
one of the built-in
abstractions that
Ur/Web applications use
is channels for passing messages
between different machines.
So each channel has a
type, which expresses what
kind of data can flow over if.
You don't have to convert
things to and from string
or JSON or anything
else to make this work.
And channels can
live in the database.
So imagine this picture
is showing us there's
a channel that was created.
It has a write side
and a read side,
which can go to separate places.
The write end is
sitting in the database.
And the read end somehow
made its way to the client
and is sitting in the variable
environment of a thread.
So imagine that thread
earlier made a remote call
to the server, which
created the channel,
returned it to the client, and
put it in the database in one
transaction.
So later, the server decides,
OK, I'll query that channel out
of the database.
And I'll dump a value into it.
And it just sort of pops out
the other end on the client.
And everything is strongly
tied throughout this process.
All right, I think this is the
last step of my animation here.
Any questions about this model
before I switch to a code demo?
STUDENT: So how is this
different than [INAUDIBLE]?
Why do you need a message
passage if you already
have that [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: OK, so RPC
interface is going from browser
initiates the call,
the server handles it.
The message is that
the channels are
intended for cases where
the server initiates
the communication.
For instance, new
email message-- that
would be a canonical example.
And the client is waiting to
hear that there's a new email
message.
But it can't
determine on its own
when the next
message is available.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Are all the
messages multiplexed
through one connection,
or is it [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: They
are multiplexed
through one HTTP connection.
I know there are these
newfangled things today called
web sockets and maybe
some other protocols
like that, which didn't exist
when this was implemented.
This all works over
old-school HTTP
with one connection for all the
messages on different channels.
All right, let's
see what's next.
Yeah, let me switch
to a demo here.
So here's a Hello World
program in Ur/Web.
Probably it deserves
more of the screen space
than this compilation output.
So it looks pretty un-scary
at this point, I hope.
The unusual thing here
maybe is that this is really
the whole program.
There's no extra
routing logic that
explains how to map a
URL into some code to run
to serve requests to that URL.
We just have regular
functions of a standard kind
of programming language.
And the compiler exposes all the
functions in your main module
as callable via URLs.
And the URL is just formed
from the function name.
And if there's some
nested structure modules,
the module's structure is
also replicated in the URL.
And then we have a
function that returns
a piece of XHTML syntax.
The compiler is actually using
a special parsing extension
for processing
this XHTML syntax.
And it's also doing
some basic type
checking to make sure that
different XML elements appear
inside others that
they're actually
authorized to appear inside of.
And I think I compiled
this before we started.
And it does a not
very surprising thing
in the browser.
And here's the HTML
page that comes out.
So among other properties,
it automatically
adds the right XHTML header.
And it declares the character
encoding for this document.
I was mildly horrified
to look at some
of your assigned
reading for this class
and see how much time this book
spends talking about character
encodings and what happens
if you're not using UTF-8.
I hope I understood
that correctly.
This forces you to use UTF-8
so that those horrible things
aren't going to happen, I hope.
But if anyone sees
a way to replicate
any of the attacks from that
book Tangled Web in Ur/Web,
or has a hypothesis
about something
we should try to
see if it works,
I'd be interested to hear that.
And by the way, at any
point during this demo,
please suggest
experiments that come
to mind about things
we should try,
mistakes you might make that you
wonder whether this system is
able to catch.
I think that's the
most fun kind of demo.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So things
like CRSF [INAUDIBLE],
you said that [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM CHLIPALA: So cross
site request forgery
I wanted to explain a
little later explicitly.
I think the paper sort of
explains why cross site
scripting can't work.
And the reason is whenever
you build a piece of syntax,
it's an object, a
tree of different sub
parts of that syntax.
It's not just a string.
And you're not going
to accidentally turn
a string from the user
into a tree with structure.
You would know if you did that.
Because it's hard to
write an interpreter.
And in Ur/Web, you have
to write an interpreter.
It doesn't automatically
happen for you.
But I'll have an example
shortly that might also
address that concern.
So I want to show you what
this syntactic sugar actually
turns into in the compiler.
So this might look
like we could just
add some double quotes
around the HTML,
and then we're back
in the normal world.
We might wonder, why
is it such a big deal
the omit the double quotes
and put XML instead?
So we can actually
take my word for it
that this is equivalent
code for what this does.
So tag is a built in
function that builds a tree
node of an HTML document.
And I'm passing a bunch of
arguments that are expressing
the CSS styling on that node.
This one doesn't really
have anything going on,
so it's a variety of different
ways of saying nothing.
And it doesn't take
any attributes.
And the tag is a body tag.
So that's another thing
in the standard library.
All of the standard tags are
functions with first class
status in the standard library.
And then we need to put a
"Hello World" text inside it.
So we call a cdata
function where
cdata is the XML word
for character data
or just a string constant.
And we can put exactly
the text from below.
We'll comment that out.
This should give us the
same result as before.
Let me see if that worked.
OK, and now I'll go
back to the actual page.
Same thing as before, so this
is what that function was really
doing at the begin.
It's not just building a string.
It's calling a
series of operations
that are designed
so that they only
allow you to build valid
HTML, and they never
implicitly interpret a string
as code instead of just
content that sits there.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Right,
you are anticipating
the next few steps.
Let me do something
less complicated
first, which is also
potentially worrisome.
Let's decide that we're really
happy to see the world, so we
better put the word "hello" in
bold and compile that again.
It just shows up as
interpreting that literally
as text instead of markup.
So this presentation
of HTML syntax
as a function that
builds syntax doesn't
have any of the usual
syntactic encoding
conventions built into it.
It interprets things in the
way you would want it to.
And so the
implementation of cdata
does what's usually
called escaping.
But the programmer
doesn't need to know there
is any such thing as escaping.
You can just think
of it as, here's
a set of convenient functions
for building a tree object that
describes a page.
Did I see a question over there?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: You want to see
the HTML that it generates.
OK, it's going to be not
the most exciting thing.
I don't know if
that's [INAUDIBLE].
I can make it bigger, but then
it doesn't fit on one line.
So let me know if I
should make it bigger.
It just put in the usual escapes
for the less than character
with an ampersand.
STUDENT: So given that
you're using XHTML,
couldn't you just use
the cdata [INAUDIBLE]
instead of doing
manual [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Probably.
That would require me knowing
more about XML than I do.
All right, so there was another
question about JavaScript URLs,
which is a good one.
If we allow JavaScript
URLs, then we
have a back door for automatic
interpretation of strings
as programs at runtime.
And that causes all
sorts of issues.
So let's try to avoid that.
I'll switch back, first of all,
to the shorter version of this.
And then inside the body,
I'll make this multiple lines.
And let's put a link that tries
to do something appropriate.
We'll leave some room
for error messages here.
This is working correctly.
Invalid URL, JavaScript
something, passed bless.
So bless is a built
in function that
is the gatekeeper of
which URLs are allowed.
And by default, no
URLs are allowed.
So certainly this
one is not allowed.
And in general, it is a bad
idea to write your URL policy
so that you can create values
that represent JavaScript URLs.
Because then all sorts of
guarantees that you might like
are invalid.
To make it a little
clearer how it
works, let me factor this
code into a separate function
called a linker
that takes in a URL.
So URL is a type.
It's not just string.
It's a type that stands for
a URL that is explicitly
authorized by your
application's policy.
And so we can [INAUDIBLE] XML.
And instead of a constant,
I'll just put u here.
And so I'm using
the curly braces
like in some popular
HTML template frameworks
to indicate inserting
some code from the host
language inside the HTML
that we're building.
And this is all
done in a way where
it's type checked statically.
So the system will
check, yeah, this
is a spot where a URL belongs.
And this says it is a URL.
So that's fine.
And then I can explicitly expose
the call to bless by saying,
let's just call the
linker function here
on the result of
blessing that URL.
We should get basically the
same error message as before.
There's some program analysis
going on here to figure out--
I guess it doesn't need that.
Because this string is
passed directly to bless.
And we can see-- I couldn't wait
to run this for you at runtime
and discover the failure.
But I can tell it's
definitely going to fail.
So I'll just make
it a compiler error.
This URL is not going to be
accepted by the URL policy.
STUDENT: So if you didn't
have the [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: If I left
out this call to bless,
it would be a much more
basic compile time error.
You have a string
and need a URL.
They're different types.
All right, but let's make this
a little more interesting.
And I'm going to open
up the configuration
file for this demo.
It's pretty short,
as these things go,
at least if you look at any
Java web application framework.
They have these gigantic
XML files for configuration.
This is a little nicer
than that, or so I claim.
We can add a rule that
says, anything on Wikipedia
is allowed.
And then we can put the
Wikipedia URL in here.
Now we're in good shape.
What's missing?
Oh, I guess I don't remember
the URL scheme for that.
But we got to the website.
That's good enough.
All right, so the
big idea here is
to have an abstract
type of URL, just
like you could have an
abstract type of hash tables
that encodes invariants about
how the hash table looks
and prevents code from
reaching inside the array
of the hash table.
We can do the same
thing for URLs.
And the system enforces
via this bless function
that every value
of this type has
passed the appropriate
check at some point.
And for instance,
with this policy,
we know there will never
be a JavaScript URL.
And it's safe to take a URL
value and use it as a link.
It won't break the basic
abstractions of the language.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: OK, so we have
to try something like that.
And this should go through.
And then the browser
knows it's a quote.
And we can look at the source.
That is because it was
escaped in the right way.
STUDENT: But can you still
use-- so JavaScript allows you
to say, [INAUDIBLE], and then
specify inline JavaScript
there.
Is that something
that [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yes and no.
So we can put body onload.
And instead of JavaScript,
you put some Ur/Web code
that does something.
So it would be a disaster
to interpret JavaScript code
in string form as
a program there.
But we can put code of
the same programming
language you're working
with already escaped in
with these curly braces.
And then it automatically
gets compiled
to JavaScript to
run on the client.
All right, any more questions?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: I
think it's everything?
Is it embarrassing
that I said everything?
Is there something that
shouldn't be allowed?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM CHLIPALA: I see, so
symbols that would independently
have funny things happening
with software execution
would confuse the human user?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM CHLIPALA: OK, I remember
reading some of that stuff.
And maybe it said the
new browser versions
avoid those problems.
But some old ones
will get confused.
It's possible this will create
problems in the old ones that
are too permissive.
I'm not sure.
But at least all
these things are
going to be interpreted as UTF-8
if they go into the document.
So if there's some problem
with a different encoding,
it shouldn't be applicable here.
Yeah.
STUDENT: The string of
the [INAUDIBLE], right now
it's checking a compile
time that that string is
on allowed URL.
But if you compute
a string at runtime,
does bless perform
a check at runtime
whether or not the
string is allowed, or are
you not allowed to--
ADAM CHLIPALA: So let's a write
a form to test that claim.
So we can put a form in here.
And form wants us to enter
URL in a text box called URL.
Then we can have
a Submit button.
When you click on it, it
should call the linker function
with a record of one value
for every field in the form.
In this case, there's
just one field called URL.
And so linker will get
passed a record that contains
the URL as a string type.
And then we'll explicitly
try to bless it up there
and see if it works.
This is an example of
an exciting type error
message, which is admittedly
sub-optimal in some ways.
Here's one of those things that
won't make any sense if you're
not familiar with Haskell.
I forgot a return.
But at least now it looks
more like a Java program.
Have a string-- let me scroll
to the end, do one of these,
sort of copying the full
type of all the attributes
that this tag can take.
And I also forgot to say,
this is now a full page.
So we can't use an a tag
until we're inside a body tag.
And this is the
abstruse type error
message for that property.
OK, so now let's
see what happens.
URL is-- yay.
There we go.
So that was a somewhat long
and not necessarily super
exciting answer
to your question.
Yeah.
STUDENT: The URL [INAUDIBLE],
are those just for [INAUDIBLE],
or is it more
restrictive than that?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It's
more restrictive.
It's currently just
constants and prefixes.
But you can also
have disallow rules.
And they run in the
order that you write.
STUDENT: Oh, so if you stick to
disallow JavaScript [INAUDIBLE]
that if you put a line break
in the middle of the word
"JavaScript," it will
still interpret it as--
ADAM CHLIPALA: That
would be too bad.
That's why it's good to stick to
the white list approach instead
of the black list approach.
So you probably
want all the rules
to start with a particular
protocol, like HTTP,
and only allow things that
fall in your approved set
of protocols.
That's what I recommend it is.
Yeah.
STUDENT: For many
sites, you might
let users share links,
in which case, you need
to allow links to anywhere.
ADAM CHLIPALA: You
can allow links.
Well, do you want your users
to share JavaScript links
or, I don't know, Flash
links, or whatever's allowed?
You see, you can white list
all the HTTP, HTTPS, URLs
and be in good shape
for most websites.
That would do that.
And the guarantees
are a little weaker
compared to allowing
only particular URLs.
But you can at least ensure that
there's no automatic execution
of the string as a program.
So let me pull up one of the
examples from the paper, which
is this one, an example
of a simple system
with a set of chat rooms
represented in the database.
And the user can click
on a link to go to a room
and then send a message.
This was the first of several
variants on that scheme.
First, I'll point out I'm
going to recompile this.
And then magically,
all the database tables
that it declares are going
to be added to the database.
And we can now just start
using the application.
But first, we have
to add some rooms.
So let's open our [INAUDIBLE]
interface to the demo database
and insert into the room table
some values like one and two.
Hopefully these are here now.
OK, and we go in
there, and we can
entertain ourselves all day
long sending strings of text.
Maybe a little more interesting,
you can try to send HTML,
and it just gets
handled right away.
That's the basic
functionality there.
And just to quickly go over
some of how this works again,
so we have these
two SQL table that
are just declared
in this first class
way inside the
programming language.
And we give the
schema of each table.
And then later, when we
try to access those tables,
the compiler will check
that we're accessing them
in a way that's consistent
with the schema from a typing
perspective.
So we have a table of
rooms where each room is
a record of an ID,
which is the integer,
and a title, which
is the string.
This is the type we were
just generating records in.
And I created a few
rooms at the SQL console.
And we also have messages that
each message belongs to a room.
And it has a time
when it was posted.
And it has some text, which
is the content of the message.
And let me fast forward
to the main function.
We run an SQL query.
So here's an example of
SQL syntax embedded inside
of Ur/Web.
I don't want to go through
the expansion of this one
into calling functions
from the standard library.
Because it's pretty
verbose if I do that.
But take my word for it,
this is de-sugared into calls
of functions in the
standard library that
represent the valid ways of
constructing an SQL query.
And those functions
have types that
cause them to type
check the query for you,
not just guarantee that
the syntax is reasonable.
So this gets de-sugared into
an indication of an SQL query.
And then the code
here is basically
just looping over all the rows
that come out of that query
and generating a piece
of HTML for each one.
In particular, we're
going to take the title
field of a query
result and convert that
into HTML with this notation
that involves curly braces.
And the square brackets
are additionally saying,
this isn't literally
a piece of HTML yet.
But please convert it for
me in the standard way.
So we can do that with
strings and integers
and all sorts of other types.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So if that contained
malicious HTML or something,
would that be filtered out?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It would be.
So in the usual way of
talking about these things,
escaping happens in the
way you'd want it to.
In Ur/Web, you can just think
of this as building a tree.
This is a node that
stands for some text.
Obviously text
can't do anything.
STUDENT: So if that
title was User Control,
and someone made a chat room
with the title Alert something,
that would not be JavaScript?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It
wouldn't automatically
be interpreted as JavaScript
or HTML or anything else.
It would just be text only.
All right, so we
have this title.
And let's wrap an
a tag around it.
And instead of href, the usual
way to do a link in HTML,
we use the link
attribute, which is
sort of a pseudo
attribute in Ur/Web, which
takes as an argument
not a URL, but basically
an Ur/Web expression.
And the meaning is when
you click on this link,
please run this expression
to generate the new page that
should be displayed.
In this case, we're
calling a function called
chat, which is defined up here.
And here's what it is.
I won't go too much
into the details.
But we have a few
more SQL queries
using a variety of
standard library functions
for different ways of
using queried results.
We generate this HTML page.
And we say, you're
in the chat room.
Here's the title.
We get the same kind
of escaping there.
And there's a form where the
user can enter some text.
That's the form that I
used to demonstrate this
a few moments ago.
And the Submit
button of the form
has this ask attribute
that is containing say,
which is the name of
a function in Ur/Web.
And here it is.
So when we submit the form,
we call this function.
Run some more SQLs.
Insert a new row into a table.
We automatically jump in
the ID of the chat room
and the text field that
came from the form.
And these are automatically
escaped as necessary.
But again, you don't have
to think about escaping
in that way in Ur/Web.
Because this is just
syntax for building a tree.
It doesn't stand for a string.
So there's no way to have
strange things happen
with parsing that you
don't expect from the way
that the syntax is written.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yes, so from the
fact that there's one widget,
one GUI widget in this
form, and its name is text,
and that one is a
text box, the compiler
infers that the record that
stands for the form result
should have one element called
text that is of type string.
And this encoding the forms,
the typing rules for it
are not built into the language.
You can actually with
the type system in Ur
express as a library, what are
the operations for building
forms, and how do you check
that they're used correctly,
including what
consequences they have
of the types of
the functions that
actually handle those forms?
[INAUDIBLE]
Any other questions
about this code
before I switch to the
next step of the sequence
in versions from the paper,
which is only a small change?
All right, then here's
what I'm going to do.
It's basically taking
advantage of a way
to get enforced encapsulation
of different parts
of an application
that Ur/Web supports,
which is at least only
rarely supported elsewhere.
I'm going to take this room.
I'm going to take some
of these definitions
here and put them inside
a module that encapsulates
some of them as private.
In particular, the database
tables are going to be private.
So no one can access
them directly.
They can only access them
through a set of methods
that we provide.
So one method runs
inside a transaction.
That's what this type says.
And it produces a list
of records with ID
and title fields that stand
for which rooms are available.
And we'll also just expose
this chat operation.
And one thing I've
done here is I've
introduced a name for
the concept of an ID.
I won't just say that
an ID is an integer.
I'll say it's a new type.
And the only way the outside
world will ever get one
is to list all the rooms.
And the only way the outside
world can ever use one
is to call the chat
function on it.
So just like, say,
the abstract type
of a hash table inside
a hash table class where
the details of what is
an ID and how do they get
produced internally are
private to this module.
And the client code
that calls this module
isn't going to need to use them.
So I'll use this syntax
to put everything
down here inside the
module so it's not
exposed to the rest of
the code by default.
And we also are going to want
to implement this rooms method.
We already happen
to have chat around.
But we can implement
rooms in a simple way
as using another
standard library
function for interpreting
a query in a useful way.
Let's just select everything
from the room table
ordering by title.
And as usual, this query
is type checked for us.
And the system determines,
OK, this expression
is going to generate
a list of records
that happens to match
the type that we declared
in the signature of this module.
So now outside this
module, no other code
is allowed to mention the room
table or the message table.
So we can, at least
from the perspective
of this application,
enforce whenever
invariance we want on them.
We can even hide
secrets inside of them
that would be a security problem
if some other part of the code
was able to get a hold of them.
Yeah.
STUDENT: But couldn't some
other part of the code
just declare table room as well?
ADAM CHLIPALA: That would
be a different table.
We could do that, actually.
It's got to be in here.
I think this should have
no effect on the behavior.
I think in this case
we're going to get
something funny happening.
Let's put this in
a different module
just to avoid something goofy.
Great, so we can do that.
And we can do whatever
we want with this table.
And I'll compile this in
maybe about 30 seconds
and we'll see what happens.
But it's actually
a different table,
just like if you have
the same private field
name across two classes in Java
they're different field names.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: So you're
suggesting we have,
inside this module,
an abstract type
called room, which contains
both the ID and the title.
Is that right?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
So I think what would
work to do instead
is instead of type
ID have type room,
have room determine
a list of rooms,
and chat take a
room as an input.
Is that what you have in mind?
So what would happen then is
when we call the chat function,
it'll actually be
called via a URL given
the way we use this eventually.
That would be passing
the ID and the title
within the URL in the URL
representation for a function
call.
And we only need the ID to
implement that function.
So it would be a little
wasteful of space
and might look gross
to the user to have
to have the title passed
along as an extra argument
in the invocation
of chat via a URL.
Does that make sense?
Or maybe another
way of saying it,
if I have this one [INAUDIBLE],
is look up at the URL bar.
The ID of the channel
we're going into
is serialized automatically
in the URL at the end here.
And if we were
passing a record that
contained an ID and
a title, the title
would be serialized, too,
which is at least a little
counterintuative.
OK, the last thing we
need to do-- actually,
it might be instructive to
make just a shallow change
to this code, reference the
room module there, and then try
to access the room
table like before.
This shouldn't be allowed.
This would be like being
able to read and write
the private fields
of a class in Java.
And indeed, we get a pretty
straightforward message
basically saying, this right
here is an unbound variable.
There's no table
called room in scope.
And we could mention
this extra one
that we created just for fun.
But then it would be
a different table.
It wouldn't be a problem
that we could access that.
So instead, what we should do is
I'll break this into two parts.
We'll start out by just
calling the rooms method,
and then do a slightly different
thing to read its elements,
map over the list of results
that gives-- what did I call
[INAUDIBLE]?
Map all the list of results
instead of the other way it
was working, which was roughly
equivalent except for using
different data types.
Let's see how this goes.
All right, so I'll go back here.
And we can do all the
tremendously exciting things
we could do before.
But we have this encapsulation.
And you can sort of think
of this room structure
as now it's a library,
and you can call this
from all sorts of
different places
that want to have
this functionality.
You don't have to worry.
There's different
places that are
going to break the internal
invariance of the system.
Maybe you want to know that
once a message is added,
it will never be deleted.
It's always there in the logs.
This structure enforces
that independently
of which other code the room
module might be composed with,
for instance.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Say you change
the definition of room,
[INAUDIBLE].
What's going to happen
to the database table?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It'll
be a little sad.
We'll have to manually run
an alter table command if you
want to save the old data.
But when the
application starts up,
it queries the system
database catalog and checks
that the schema still
matches what it expects.
So you'll get a
static error then.
And that will hopefully give
you a hint about what you
should change in the database.
STUDENT: But it
wouldn't automatically
drop your database or something?
ADAM CHLIPALA: I hope not.
I don't think it should do that.
And you can imagine
tweaking the compiler
to understand the
evolution of a database.
I think you have to write
alter table commands to run.
It doesn't do that right now.
OK, so now let's talk about
cross site request forgery
and preventing it.
Actually, before
we do that, let's
look at the code on this page.
We have a traditional
looking HTML form
that gets generated here.
And there's certainly no cross
site request forgery protection
in here, which I think is good.
Because as I understand
cross site request forgery,
the problem is there's
some implicit context
that your application
sends on every request.
So there's some
attacker out there
who doesn't know your
implicit context.
Let's say your password
is stored in a cookie,
for a really simple example.
And when the attacker tricks
you into following a link
to the application, your browser
sends the implicit context
automatically and
causes the application
to do something the attacker
could not have done directly.
In this case, there's
no implicit context.
So there's no risk of a
cross site request forgery.
Does anyone want to dispute
that characterization
before I go on?
It could be educational for me.
All right, so now let's
add some implicit context.
And the system is
automatically going
to deploy the right
countermeasures based
on program analysis
that realizes
now there's implicit context.
In particular, we just
throw in a cookie here.
As another example of
module capsulation,
actually, I'll put in a whole
sort of user authentication
system where we have the user
accounts and abstract types
of IDs and passwords.
So you can't just build the
value of either of these types
directly.
You'll have to go
through some kind
of approved method of building
values of these types.
And I'm actually going to
expose the table directly
in the signature.
And I'll put a
constraint on it, too,
saying the ID form
is a key for it.
[INAUDIBLE]
But the thing is,
on this user table,
ID and password
are abstract types.
So the code can't actually
look at the password.
And it can't generate
all IDs in sequence
and try them against this table.
Because the type is abstract.
There's no way to make an ID.
There's no way to
make a password.
They just come
out of this table,
and they're opaque tokens.
But we might want to allow
them to be input from strings.
You might want to allow
one direction of conversion
between strings and these types.
So that's what I'll do here.
Basically, the details I
don't want to try to explain.
But this is like
a declaration, OK,
you're allowed to
convert strings into IDs.
For those who speak Haskell,
this is a type class instant.
For those who don't,
it's permission
to turn strings into IDs.
We're going to leave out
the other permission.
We don't want to be able to
turn an ID back into anything.
And the password--
let's do the same thing.
We want to be able to read
a password from the user
but not take a password
and turn it into a string
where we can actually tell
what the user entered.
So other parts of
the code will be
able to accept password
input from the user,
convert it into this type, and
ship it off to the user module
and have it be checked.
But what they can't do
is query the user table
and get all the passwords in
a form where they can actually
extract the text from them.
Then we can have a login method
that takes these two components
and just runs for its side
effects, which is effectively
what that code says.
We'll also need a way to
tell which user is logged in.
That is a code that
runs a transaction that
produces an ID.
All right, so step one, we
can just copy this definition.
And I'll fill in what
these actually are.
It turns out-- surprise,
surprise-- user IDs
and passwords are both strings.
But outside the module,
that won't be exposed.
And now we're going
to create a cookie.
So cookies are another thing
that's built into the language.
Effectively, they act like
mutable global variables
that have one copy per client
that uses your application.
So we're going to create a
cookie that on each client
will store basically just a
copy of the same two fields
that we have here.
So this cookie is
private to this module.
Other parts of the code won't
be able to read the cookie,
because they just don't have
this private field and scope.
So no one else will be
able to see directly
the ID and password that
are stored for this user.
But they will be persisted
across different page views,
just like you would expect
for cookies usually.
I'm going to give it a
login function that's
going to run some incantation
to check against the database
whether this is really a correct
pair of username and password.
It'll just check,
can we find a row
in the database that has this
user ID and has this password?
If we find one, then yes,
good, that's the correct value.
Let's just save it
into the cookie.
We use a method that
modifies the cookie value.
And we have to put
some things in here,
like just for simplicity, I'll
say this cookie never expires.
And I don't want
to run SSL here,
so I'll say it doesn't
need to be secure.
But if you really
care about security,
obviously you would
write secure equals true.
And if the check failed,
then we can-- I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
If it signals an
error, execution
stops with this
error description.
Finally, we can
create this function
that tells who the user
is logged in as by getting
the current cookie value.
And then it might be
none if the user hasn't
logged in yet, in which case,
we can have a different error
message.
Or it might be some
record of exactly the type
we used up there.
So I'll just copy
some of this here.
Let's run the same check there.
If it worked, then
we'll just return
the ID part of the
record that we just
verified against the database.
Otherwise, [INAUDIBLE].
So let me just type check this
to see if this is on track,
that part-- Oops, capital Id.
All right, so the
important is there's all
those implementation details.
But from outside this
module, we think of it
in terms of the
interface up there.
There are some unknown
types of IDs and passwords.
This table of users
expressed in terms of them
were allowed to turn strings
into IDs and passwords, but not
the other way around.
And we have these two methods
to log in in the first place
and to check which user is
logged in at this point.
Any question about this?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Do you need to
expose the user table?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Because I want to
use it as a foreign key later.
That was the reason I did it.
It's not that great of a reason.
All right, so we're
almost at the point
where I can show you CSRF
protection in action.
We have to actually
start logging in.
So that's easy enough to do.
OK, so what can we do here?
Let's just add another part
of this page that says,
here's where you log in.
This is the form.
This is where you would put
the username and the password.
And then click on the button.
It's trying to go to call
a function called login,
which we'll define in a moment.
Let's define login as a
function that does these things.
It's actually just a wrapper
around calling the login
function from that module where
we take each of the components
and convert it from string
to the abstract types.
That's what read error is doing.
Error means if it doesn't
work, just abort execution
instead of signaling the failure
with a special return value.
Here's both of those, login
and then jump to main.
So now we should
be able to log in.
Let's check if that's true.
OK, so that was [INAUDIBLE].
We'll probably want to create an
account to allow us to log in.
So let me [INAUDIBLE].
So now I should be
able to log in as a.
OK, and take my word for it.
There's now a cookie set
to record that information.
And then let's go back in the
chat room and send a message.
We didn't actually add any
access control here yet.
So there's not
much going on here.
But we can check to see.
There's a cookie.
But the system has
determined that we're not
using the cookie.
When we submit this form,
the cookie is not read.
So there's actually no need to
add any CSRF protection here
yet.
So now we have to add the
way to use the cookie.
And then we should see
the protection appear.
Yeah.
STUDENT: What are the
contents of the cookie?
ADAM CHLIPALA: What are
the contents of the cookie?
The contents are exactly what
you'd expect from the code.
In other words, the
cookie is declared
as having type this record,
an ID, and a password.
So that's exactly
what's in there
in a particular serialized form.
So now let's actually
use the cookie.
And we should hopefully
see despite the fact
we're going to use
the cookie indirectly,
because we're going to use it in
the room module, which doesn't
even have the cookie in scope.
But we'll call methods of the
user module, which indirectly
are using the cookie.
And then the system
will realize that means
we have dependency on it.
So let's make this really
simple and just say
call the whoami method.
And I'm actually just
going to ignore this.
Or we can do this.
Let's decide this a user we
created is really special.
And only this user is
allowed to post anything.
And we'll fail if we're not a.
All right, let's
see if this works.
Did I forget a slash somewhere?
Oh, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Oh, I expect him to be a string.
But it's actually an ID.
So let's just read a into
an ID just like we did below
to process login.
And we haven't
exposed that the ID
type supports equality testing.
So I'll just add that
to the user module.
And then that should work.
ID supports equality testing.
And we should be OK.
So now we've brought
in the interface.
Now we can do more things
with the ID, which could
trigger some security issues.
But it lets us add this
access control check,
so let's see how that works,
go back to the main page
to [INAUDIBLE].
All right, now the
form automatically
has a hidden input
name sig, which
is a cryptographic signature
of the values of all
of the cookies.
And it's signed using a key
that's a secret for the server.
And when the form is
submitted, the application
knows, because the
compiler told it,
that it should be checking
signatures for the following
set of operations.
In this case, the only
one is this say operation.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Does the signature have
any sort of time stamp as well?
ADAM CHLIPALA: It does
not have a time stamp.
STUDENT: Otherwise, if the
attacker ever saw this live,
they could pretend
to be the user.
It never expires.
ADAM CHLIPALA: It
never expires, right.
So that's something that
could be changed just
by modifying the
language implementation
without modifying
the applications,
and then deployed instantly.
But it's not there now.
And I can see why that could
be a useful thing to add.
Question, yeah.
STUDENT: You could also fix that
by just putting an [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
ADAM CHLIPALA: That's true.
You're right, you can
change the application
to purposely modify the
cookie data frequently enough
that the signature
would go out of date.
That's also true.
So we've got 10 minutes left.
Any requests for things that
someone particularly wants
to see before class is over?
I can start showing some
Ajax stuff by default
if no one has another request.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Can you remap the URLs?
ADAM CHLIPALA: You can, yes.
So what remapping
would you like to see?
STUDENT: Any.
I just want to
see how it's done.
ADAM CHLIPALA: OK,
so the compiler
is assigning-- as we
can see back over here,
we called the say function.
And basically,
that function call
is serialized as a
particular URL form.
Maybe we don't like that form.
We decide we're going
to rewrite URL so say
is inside the room
module, inside demo.
Better put this
up top so it runs
before these other rewrites--
rewrite url Demo/Room/say
into Demo/Room/speak.
And hopefully that's
what I want it to.
Let's see what happens.
Yep, and you can have
wild cards in those rules
also to map one
prefix to another one.
And the compiler will
enforce that every function
has a distinct URL schema.
So if you add a rule
that causes a clash,
you'll get [INAUDIBLE].
By default, the
automatically generated
URL schemes are [INAUDIBLE].
You can break that by
using this feature.
Any other requests?
Yeah.
STUDENT: So you mentioned
that the HTML [INAUDIBLE]
is not compiler specific.
It's like one is a library.
Are there other libraries
for other formats as well?
ADAM CHLIPALA: There
are other libraries
that don't do type checking
at the same level of richness.
But for instance,
there's a library
for serializing and
de-serializing JSON.
And most of the
automated way that's
driven by type structure.
So you can do things like
that that aren't as integrated
with the compiler.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Presumably you'd
still want to write JavaScript.
Is there any--
ADAM CHLIPALA: I don't.
You do.
STUDENT: Right, no, but
for, say, I don't know,
you want to animate
things on the page.
There are still things where--
ADAM CHLIPALA: Let me load
the Ajax version of this.
And that might
answer your question.
[INAUDIBLE]
All right, so this version
has client side code.
Let's just [INAUDIBLE].
Believe it or not, this time
the add worked by an Ajax call.
And you get things like,
here's a button tag.
And it has an onclick
attribute that when
a user clicks the button,
all this code here
runs on the client side.
But it's Ur/Web code.
It's not JavaScript code.
The compiler translates
it into JavaScript for you
and guarantees that it maintains
the properties that we want
for the abstractions
in our list,
as long as the user isn't
mucking around with it manually
[INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: I'm more
thinking that there
are a lot of
[INAUDIBLE] libraries
out there today that do useful
things, and in many cases
complex things if you want to
recode everything yourself.
Is there any way interfacing
JavaScript from Ur/Web?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Yes, there's
a foreign function interface,
which lets you give Ur/Web
function names to JavaScript
function names and call.
But then whenever you use the
foreign function interface,
you don't get all of these nice
properties like construction
anymore.
You have to be very careful.
And to some extend, you have to
understand the implementations
of some of these abstractions
to avoid disturbing them.
While I have this code up
here, let me just show you.
We still have the same say
function as before, roughly.
But now, instead of
calling it via a link,
we just take the
function call, which
is populated with arguments
that come about from the context
of this onclick handler.
And we just wrap that function
called inside the RPC syntax.
And that means this is a
function call on the client,
but run the call itself
on the server with access
to the database and
other server resources,
and then shift the
result back over here.
And it's written in
this direct style
here instead of the
callbacks that you
need to use in
JavaScript usually
to accomplish a remote
server call [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADAM CHLIPALA: The
client is allowed
to call anything in scope.
So you just have to
use scope the way
we usually use it to
hide private fields
and so forth inside
of an abstraction.
I mean, because
there's a call here,
the functions we're
allowed to call
are the ones whose
names are in scope.
This name happens to
not be in scope here.
So we couldn't call
it directly here.
But because it's
in scope up there,
we're allowed to call it.
Did I see another hand?
Let's see, is
there anything else
interesting about this version
that I wanted to mention?
It involves an implementation
of a GUI widget using
this functional
reactive style, which
is cool from a programming
modularity perspective
but maybe less interesting
from a security perspective.
But here's an example of calling
a method of this abstraction
of a portion of the
page that displays
a list of lines of
text that you can
add to but never delete from.
And you can actually
enforce that.
Because we don't
have the dom here.
It's not that any
part of the code
can reach into the document
tree and mutate it and change
the log and delete lines
that were previously added.
The more functional
style here means
you can actually have
a GUI widget that
owns a part of the
page and controls
exactly what's shown there,
and bugs and other code
can't interfere with
computing what shows up there.
This is probably
good point to stop,
unless there are
any last questions.
STUDENT: Channels?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Channels.
I don't think there's enough
time to properly demonstrate
channels.
But there's code in the paper.
And there are all sorts
of demos and tutorials
on the website for this project.
Yeah.
STUDENT: It's really hard
writing correct [INAUDIBLE]
and compilers.
How do you mitigate
problems that
might be present from the
abstraction layers themselves?
ADAM CHLIPALA: Get people
to use it and report bugs.
That's the best I have for you.
I guess the idea is
compilers like this
should be written
much less frequently
than new applications.
So to condense all the bug
finding in this one place
is still an improvement,
even if it's not
done in a particularly
principled way.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Just out
of curiosity, how
are [INAUDIBLE] files handled?
ADAM CHLIPALA: You can
use that configuration
file I showed to map them
into parts of the URL space.
Or you can manually
produce values
in the program that
stand for files
and ask to return those
as the result of the page.
There are a few
different approaches.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Why Ur?
ADAM CHLIPALA: You're
asking how I chose the name?
STUDENT: Yeah, like why--
ADAM CHLIPALA: Oh, you're
asking why you want to use this.
STUDENT: No, no, the
name of the language,
just out of curiosity.
ADAM CHLIPALA: So Ur language
is a concept from linguistics
to describe the language
that is the ancestor
of the modern languages.
And the idea is
in this language,
you can embed all sorts of
other languages inside it.
So it's sort of the
ancestor of all those.